oh
penny
where the heck is penny
there is no better time than right now
to introduce my girl penny
if you're with me can you write team
thick in the comments below
my current favorite is this thick lid if
you know a proper woman in her
bunny costume i also like the tail
definitely the tail
all these size zero girls are good but
to be honest i just want the uh the
thick girl from save the world
i think she's called penny ladies and
gentlemen we finally did it
after three years of begging the mascot
of team thick
is now in fortnite br penny is here
i decided to record my reaction to her
hitting the shot today
and then invited a load of you guys to
play a few games with her i hope you
enjoy it
let's do this so
this is the day i can't believe it this
is the day
coming soon the original constructor
joins the battlefield
three years i've been asking for this
two minutes 47 seconds 11
10 seconds until history is made and
team thick has their matriarch
in battle royale please please be here
penny i've missed you so much
here we go here we go penny
girl here we are my god she's dead
oh she looks so good she looks so good
and i don't have the v-bucks
i'll be back in a minute okay i can't
believe it's taking us three years to
get a female thick skin
but it's happened and she looks good she
looks different doesn't she
her face is very different hmm purchase
that bad boy
penny you and i are now together
construction crew
she doesn't come with a bag bling okay
that's interesting
i get those boost gumps every time i
pennies everywhere the greatest
lobby ever it looks good it looks like
nobody's fake to everyone
who said they have it have it so far
we have oh my word penny you look good
everyone we are going to hut watch
don't build if you don't mind just land
on hut watch or somewhere around there
and start dancing we have to take penny
[Music]
home
[Music]
penny is home this will become penny's
home
check out these funky ladies absolute
perfection
okay you guys go and hide in lazy lake
we're playing a game of hide and seek
oh dude come back here you
dude white
thanks for playing diego but you broke
the rules how did you get the code
whoever wins this i will add you to my
friends list and i will gift you
something random
i never thought this day would come look
at all these
thick people
[Music]
okay penny we're gonna play this game
has now become penny says okay
penny says jump
penny says crouch
penny says why are you late okay go go
on you gotta always keep going
try and get in the line get in the line
get in the line
he survived nicely done uh jump
hey thank you who's the other person
would you mind coming out
come on honesty is the best policy you
have my respect if you can take the shot
you stay
you stay penny says spin round
oh in fact come here will you please
[Applause]
penny says come to me stop
i could have killed you all then so many
of you did that
okay penny says default dance
okay penny says run around in circles
i'm going to randomly snipe
so sorry about that michael penny say
stop
whoever that is it's getting sniped i'm
so sorry penny says
run okay penny says make a straight line
in the circle behind me
i'm the one jumping and he says make a
perfect line behind me
two one
nice do the same on the other side
excellent oh no was it in the storm
oh some dog sick that's so good dude
stay in your line stay in your life stay
light knock again the circle
penny says get in the circle what's
gonna happen now
i'm gonna run around and you should know
what i look like
okay do you all know what i look like
the person who kills me with a pickaxe
don't do it yet is going to win if
anyone shoots a bullet they are
disqualified
okay please move out the way please move
out the way
so in five seconds whoever kills me with
the pickaxe
is the winner go
you pick action
oh who got that who got that little ck
little
you are officially our champion of the
first ever
penny meet-up
i love that you're dancing right now i
love it well done
well done you're all awesome people and
it's only it's only three o'clock in the
morning let's play some more games i
love this community
so that was our meet up with our penny
skins i can't believe she's in the shop
it blows my mind
we played many more games after this i'm
going to cut them down and put them over
on the second channel so if you didn't
know we had a second channel you do now
it's all about gameplay
and hopefully in the future it's about
making uploads with you guys
playing more games with more friends
having more community meetups
thank you so much if you're still here
at this point in the video and
thanks hugely to anyone who's used code
adam arrow in the store to buy penny or
anything else
on screen now are the people from last
week like usual
i'm a little bit far behind on these and
i'll be spending all this week getting
back to you all
in my twitter dms thank you so much for
choosing my code you change my life
and thanks to that i can now meet up
with you guys more often
i'm adam from playstation grenade this
is penny life is good
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you